heute wird am flughafen leipzig halle
eine corona teststation eröffnet dort
können sich dann urlauber testen lassen
freiwillig doch nur einheimische sollen
sich dort testen lassen am flughafen ist
für uns max kaczynski max wie läuft denn
jetzt die testaktion dort an wie wird
sie angenommen guten mittag hier vom
flughafen leipzig halle hinter mir ist
direkt die krone teststation halle saale
man sie tatsächlich jetzt auch gerade
dass die ersten anscheinend sich auch
dafür interessieren
ein test durchzuführen der test ist auf
freiwilliger basis und aber auch nur für
bewohner der stadt halle möglich es ist
so dass es übernommen wird
kostentechnisch bei gruner symptomen und
wenn man aus einem risikogebiet kommt
das heißt aber wenn ich jetzt nicht in
halle oder leipzig wohnen muss ich für
den test zahlen oder kann mich gar nicht
testen lassen
also konkret erst einmal es gilt nur für
bewohner der stadthalle nicht für die
leipziger sondern nur für die hallenser
und der test ist kostenfrei
wie gesagt auch nur für die länder
wenden sie aus einem risikogebiet kommt
was das rk ii bezeichnet hat und oder
wenn sie corona symptome aufweisen alle
anderen könnten sich dort auch testen
lassen
aber dann ist die geht es um die frage
der kosten dort sind dann die kosten 142
euro und 33 cent das sind die reihen
laborkosten diese einschränkung
irgendwie begründet naja ist die stadt
kann ja nicht für andere
gesundheitsämter handeln sondern kann
sich ja nur mit ihrem eigenen
städtischen alten- gesundheits- darum
kümmern das ist der grund dahinter